now that we know how we can find the
square of a number we can try to
understand what square roots are this is
a topic which many students find really
difficult to understand so here is a
chance to understand this topic well and
score better consider any number say 4 4
when squared gives us 16 and the square
root of 16 gives us 4 well that's your
concept now we shall see how we
represent square roots this is how we
would represent the square of 4 4 raised
to 2 2 is called the power and 4 is the
base now how do we represent the square
root of 4 well this is how we write it
this symbol is called the radical or the
square root and the number inside the
symbol is called the radicand or the
base that's the first thing we learnt
how to represent a square root but here
is a simple way to remember it we know
that 5 squared is 25 this 2 when
transposed to the other side becomes a
square root so we can say that the
square root of 25 is 5 now let's look at
something really interesting about the
square roots what's the square root of
16 yes it's 4 this means that if we
square 4 we will get what is under this
radical similarly the square root of 256
is 16 if we Square this we will get this
now let's try playing with these numbers
let's try writing 16 in exponential form
we know that 16 can be written as 2
raised to 4 so the square root of 16 can
be written as the square root of 2
raised to
it's the same thing as the square root
of 16 can it be written in some other
way yes it can also be written as square
root of 4 raised to 2 we just wrote 16
in two different ways to raise to 4 and
4 raised to 2 now let's try writing the
number 4 in different ways 4 can be
written as 2 squared hence this will
equal 2 squared the number 4 can also be
written as 4 raised to 1 hence this
would equal 4 raised to 1 just look at
these things now what do you observe
what happens to the base and what
happens to the exponent let's look at
the first example the base remains the
same but the exponent is haft it's
divided by 2 now let's move on to the
next expression again the base remains
the same and the exponent is haft does
this work every time let's see this can
be written as square root of 2 raised to
8 or maybe even square root of 4 raised
to 4 and 16 can be written as 2 raised
to 4 and even 4 raised to 2 in this case
the base remained the same and the
exponent was halved and in this case 2
the exponent was halved so remember when
you have a number in exponential form
and you want to find its square root
just keep the base same and have the
exponent